- So you're now a
fan-favorite of the show.
How does that feel?
- I mean, I think I'm a favorite of some-
- No, you're a fan favorite.
Everyone is very excited you were coming.
There are people on the crew
that were like, "she's coming?"
I was like, "oh my gosh."
- I think what's nice about this season
is that everyone has somebody different
to kinda plug into.
We're all pretty different, you know.
It's much more diverse, I think,
between age and ethnicity and background
and age, I'm the old one.
- Yeah.
Yeah, no one thinks about that, yeah.
I was like, "no one thinks 'old'
when they look at you."
They just think "damn, I'm not that cool."
- Yeah, no, that's not
what they're thinking,
but okay, thanks.
- They are thinking that.
Wait, did Andy Cohen have to actually
convince you to do it?
- I mean, "convince" is a strong word.
We had a come-to-Jesus, so we knew
each other prior and at the very end,
we were getting ready to sort of
do the final decision that he and I
spoke on the phone and
he said exactly that
he didn't want to convince me.
He was like, "you have
to make the decision
on your own because
it's a really vulnerable
situation and anything that you don't want
people to know, they will know."
These fans are-
they're like forensic scientists.
If any of you are out there, I know you.
I know you know everything.